bienvenue sur diagonale tv pour suivre
donc les tie breaks de ces quarts de
finale du championnat du monde féminin
2015 tie break
qui donc vont voir s'affronter maria
musi tout face à un piccone rouquine des
deux favorites souza ou aux six autres
favorites chinois cette fois qui
affronte natalia pogo nina la tombeuse
de marie sebag et puis bien sûr on a
aussi via chrome line à suédoise qui
affronte la soeur de maria anna musique
zouk donc deux ukrainiennes deux soeurs
dans ces quarts de finale
et puis on avait donc suite à la partie
aux parties longues on avait arica
l'indienne qui est déjà qualifiée en
demi-finale alors poursuivre ces quarts
de finale on va simplement regarder une
des plus belles parties de ces quarts et
puis après on fera un bilan du tableau
final qui va nous permettre de voir les
demi-finales se dessiner il ya tout
d'abord on va voir donc cette partie
entre suazo et pogo dina donc on a vu
comment pogo nina était revenu dans le
match suite à un magnifique gambie benko
qu'on avait d'ailleurs analysé et donc
là les tie-breaks ce sont des parties
rapides c'est la première des deux
parties rapides initiale à la suite de
ses deux premières parties rapides et
bien si assis à une vainqueur et bien
les qualifiés et sinon on fait d'autres
parties rapides et éventuellement
ensuite on finit par des blitz
voilà donc ici sunao débute par des cas
très bien qu'à lévis c4
et ces cinq là semble peu godina revenir
une nouvelle fois dans ce camp vivanco
qu'il a vu et bien remporté la partie
des 5
et oui quand vivanco donc on donne un
pion voilà on donne ce pion pour
éloigner un pion du centre et ouvrir les
colonnes a et b parce qu'on va jouer à
six derrière on va prendre et puis on
aura les colonnes a et b sur ses deux
pions l'afc interne était très très bien
sorti pogo nina effet une magnifique
partie superbe avec on l'a vu une
combinaison finale bon on va supposer
que dans ce type de match c'est très
intéressant parce que savoir si les
champions ils vont refaire les mêmes
coûts on peut supposer que la partie va
se suivre jusqu'à ce qu'il y ait bien
bien entendu une déviation prise bien g6
qu'elle et ses trois fous g7 pour
l'instant c'est pareil j'ai 3 g iii
petit rock ou g2 bon il y avait aussi
cette position avec le fond j'ai deux
des six qualité trois cavaliers prend
petit rock dame b si ça ressemble
beaucoup
cavalli d2 alors pas du tout la même ici
laquelle l'idée ne crois pas qu'elle ait
joué ça ici qu'ils avaient des deux vont
venir en c4 un plan qu'elle a pas mis en
oeuvre que vous avez un parti précédente
cavaliers c7 et voilà qu a blessé quatre
attaques la dame donc l'avait joué un
plan à partir à part avec à 4 plus tôt
il ça s'est avéré insuffisant donc la
ville et ses quatre dames des quatre
partis à changer de rapport au match de
partie longue et la kabylie 3 qui a été
attaquée y avait pas de ya pas de façon
simple de le protéger ce cas manière si
je viens avec la dame en b3 je peux
c'est possible mais il n'ose cas il y
aura sans doute fois ci c'est il faudra
faire quelque chose de toute façon et si
jo loubet 3 avait évidemment le calice
et 3 et on prie donc curieux 3es jeux
sur protège des cinq ont par contre je
bouge un petit peu les monnaies de ce
coup mais bon de toute façon surtout
qu'ils gardent l'oeil sur b2 parce que
voilà cette colonne est ouverte et b2 et
en étant prises fois ci ce fut bien sûr
sa case de prédilection à 1,6 il vise le
pion à eux deux la tour eiffel tourbe et
un retour d un jeu sur protège les deux
papa cavalli b5 alors on en a parlé un
petit peu fière même si ce n'était pas
possible c'était une des idées aussi le
client ces sept on peut venir en bessin
pour quoi faire
mais pour veiller en d4 cas ce forte
alors les moins fortes bien sûr si les
blancs n'ont pas encore joué que 4 parce
que si on vend des gâteaux ou tard on
pourra jouer avec les bleus 3 et le
cahier doit partir mais s'ils veulent
jouer de 4 sinon il faut pas laisser
aller le cavalier en d4 probablement
faut prendre mais si on prend et bien on
enlève un défenseur du pion à 2 et voilà
donc ça c'est un problème puisqu'il ya
une tour quand même qui a tant que ça et
si les blancs jouent à 3 pour éviter la
prise du pion mais on affaiblit des
cases et c'est ce que cherche à faire
les noirs food et deux normales
enfin c'est un peu pénible parce que la
dame est attaquée potentiellement quand
le cavaly bouge mais bon il n'a pas de
bonnes cases où aller
il peut peut-être aller aux 4 quand même
il ya en quatre attaques la dame mais la
dame à des cases probablement en d4 par
exemple sans doute pas de problème
particulier et en plus voilà qu'avec les
d4 ont maintenant six lequel il bouge
c'est pas grave on arrive la dame et il
n'y a pas de danger grave alors qu'à et
des caps faisait pression supplémentaire
sur deux bons même si cavalli et dames
protéger on met la tour en plus
oppressant et vaut mieux que la tour
fasse quelque chose que rien en face on
ne faisait rien donc quand le 200e un
pardon elle protège le 2 et
éventuellement plus tard elle devra à
des puces et 4 voire 5 pour les blancs
les mieux placés en tout cas quand les
femmes et voilà c'est fini
regardez que le développement noir se
fait facilement dingue du bingo pour un
pion on a un jeu extrêmement actif tout
est sorti et tout est contre le camp
blanc bon pour un pion b3 ça c'est la
manière classique de jouer dans me
blanco pour lui blanc on joue le pion
plutôt en b3 plutôt que de jouer le plan
qui avait joué sous sa houlette à la
fois bon b3 ça enlève maintenant un peu
du venait de ce fou mais se foulent
hamiti vise plus la casse des quatre
collections bêtement
calais 17 voilà déjà joué ça est un peu
les 17es
avait déjà joué ça la partie la libère
évidemment la puissance de ce fou et
puis ce cavalier il a envie de s'amuser
lui aussi alors par où il veut aller
peut-être en scène par exemple pour
aider à la plus est ces quatre des
choses comme ça dames c'est un
surprotège ici ça hein parce
qu'attention mais quand même un peu fou
qui attaque et plus une dame donc
maintenant six cavaliers par exemple
cavale et cf3 échec et je pouvais
prendre le cavalier bon c'était pas
grave mais au cas où il vaut mieux avoir
une protection dame bessette faut pas
blesser des parties rapides donc là en
terme de temps évidemment il faut il
faut quand même gérer ce attendu les pas
réfléchir non plus trop trop longtemps
qu avait laissé quatre places maintenant
qu'on a joué les trois claviers ou cinq
cavaliers prend ou prend alors ça ça
ressemble à ce qui s'était passé hier la
même manoeuvre de cavaliers le club
libyen 17 et vient s'échanger à un
simple hier c'était contrôle krief 3
cette fois c'est contre le carrier qui
était en c4 mais ils s'échangent voilà
on a on enlève une pièce blanche bien
placé et les pièces noires sont
maximales voilà 2 3 donc c'est ce que je
disais hier c'est pour ça que les noirs
aime bien que les blancs jouent à 4
finalement parce que le d4 la case des
quatre définitivement faible maintenant
avec eux trois baies n'allait pas faible
qu'avec b5 cavale et d un combat
un évite les changes ou g 7 à 4
qu'elle laissait 7 pouces et 3 on
élimine le puissante fou de cases noires
fou prend cavaliers prendre les blancs
ont réussi à éliminer une pièce
importante et ils n'ont pas joué aux
quatre donc ce fou et quand même un tout
petit peu plus actif que si on a joué 4
et encore boucher papillon cdsn mais oui
mais il peut passer par quatre si il
veut de la plus de cases que si on a
joué 4 les cases noires sont moins de
faibles puisque le faut a disparu bon
donc la position semble quand même plus
agréable côté blanc que ce qu'il y avait
été joué à la fois fou des trois tacles
à tour dames b4 ont très bien autour des
voici ce tour des deux tours à sept
cavaliers à deux attaques la dame bon
c'est des manoeuvres ont là rien de très
grave pour l'instant dams et 2 et voilà
comme hier boum boum on tape à montfort
sur la colonne b est pas facile de
défendre b3 l'adamo s'y rajoutent
attention b3 est en crise et bouchra
lycéens alors c'est comme hier aussi
c'était le cavalier qui défend des pions
b2 il était un des hommes maintenant on
se caille est allé en c1 pour protéger
un p3 d'un bep quatre tours à 2
oui parce que là attention il y avait
une elle un simple après dame b 4 ans
menace de jouer ces deux sans doute
prise du pion puisqu'il ya le fou et on
prenait on prend b2 donc tour à 2
2 me
à 5
cadets 1
autour des 4
h 4 h 5 manoeuvre 3 h 2 voilà ça y est
par rapport à la dernière partie
si on l'a bien en tête cette dernière
partie c'est intéressant pour suivre
celle là radix nous a volés c'était
quand même fait mater donc là du coup
cette fois elle a appris la leçon s'est
dit bon je vais le roi l'abri et je
réfléchis après voilà pour éviter de se
faire mater c'est pas plus mal
cavalli 1,8 même si on est loin d'avoir
la position tendu voilà le 4 avril 6
puis bon mais la mila est bon tac il ya
un cavalier qui venait de venir faire un
échec
elle joue très très bien ce qu'on vivait
en cours et pour une île assez
extraordinaire f3 voilà les blancs
bombés il empêche le cavalier de venir
faire un échec qui pourrait être
dangereux mais ce faisant ils bougent un
peu une nouvelle fois se fout il faut
décidément il a du mal à vivre et la c4
voilà c'est cat's eyes et c'est l'heure
pour les noirs bravé un peu de jeu on a
l'impression que les noirs peuvent
jamais perdre dans cette variante la
telle quelle la joue peu au colonel la
joue bien un ancien faut dire que là
c'est magnifique à sa façon de jouer
donc ces quatre là pression sur b3 et
maximale on n'a pas trop le choix
puis on prend fou prend attaque la tour
toi un tombé 2 et les noirs sont
ensemble très très bien pas de problème
j'ai la colonne b en plumes et l'angine
courant le deuxième qui attaquent la
tour et puis derrière il ya un fou g2
leroy h 2 il ya beaucoup de matériel on
aime bien que les tours soit sur des
colonnes
sur la deuxième et puis avec du matériel
du matos a ramassé éventuellement et
latour attention la tour d2 étant prise
de la dame bon temps du attention quand
même il ya un pion 1 4 qui est passé si
on s'amuse trop avec les noirs a5 a6 a7
et puis on va avoir des problèmes
donc quand même être resté prudent mais
on est bien la crise prises quasiment
forcé puisqu'il avait comme une menace
sur la tour et noir sont extrêmement
actifs pour arriver à activis cavaliers
maintenant puisque là il est quand même
dominé par les purs le pion f3 à l'
empêche de bouger le pion 4 empêche de
bouger un 5/6 virage 7 mais il peut pas
faire mieux sans doute donc en 17 et
venir en jeu soit par 5 soit par ces
cinq pour venir faire pression sur
détroit et sur f3 d'amd 4 alors faut
d'abord s'occuper du fou pour ces deux
protège le fou est pas facile d'attaquer
la tour si je fais d'amd important
qu'est la tour peut-être que je vous
donne ses trois attaques la torah et les
blancs des problèmes dans le 3
dam des quatre ont petit à petit on
amène la dame dangereux alors attention
à 5 à 6
ça peut des menaces mais calais détroit
d'abord n'aime pas trop ça
cavalier quand même et déjà emprise du
fouet la dame est un peu en l'air et fou
prend quand même
alors ça c'est assez pénible comme ça je
sais pas pourquoi elle a fait ça parce
que là ici elle aurait pu quand même
joué dans b3 ou voir dame ces trois cas
l'air très fort attac la tour et le
cavalier en plus cela les bouges la dame
étant prises donc le seul coup pour les
blancs ça semble être tour des uns et la
simplement cavale et 17 c'est ce qu'on
avait dit ce cas il ya plus de cela ils
viennent ces scènes plus tard et
semblerait que le caïd et 3 soit perdue
parce que comment la dame peut pas
bouger pour continuer à protéger ou
alors sur des jouets fouet fait mais on
ne peut pas on est cloué donc ça semble
extrêmement difficile l'a donc sur
calais des trois là les noirs rate dame
b3 déjà ils sont beaucoup mieux en fait
il ya une faute avant l'un sans doute et
si on ne revoie rousset qui était la
faute quand même ici jusque là ça a
l'air d'être tenir tout reprend les noms
sont quand même bien et adam des cadres
les thèmes précis probablement dam des
4es thème précis parce que tour ces deux
voilà je commence à faire un petit peu
de pression là ici ça c'est toujours
cloué le fou est bien protégé donc ce
couteau pour finalement qui laisse la
tour venir dans une belle case alors que
la dame en d1 l'empêcher de venir sur
ces 2 en plus je libère ici ah oui mais
je me lasse aussi dames 1 tavin ici la
dame revient d un jeu peu protégés par
daems et 3 donc dans des quatre ans déjà
dames 3 et 4 donc on a dit qu'elle était
trois la dame b 3 dames ces trois mêmes
c'est encore mieux et ça a l'air très
très bon pour les noirs fou prend elle
le fait bon on en prend elle a vu
quelque chose eh oui magnifique
c'est aussi bien tout reprend voilà donc
il y avait une combinaison gagnante
on sacrifie la tour regardez superbe
reprend est maintenant évident je vous
laisse deux secondes pour le trouver
dans cette position regardez donc
s'efforcer tout efforcés tout est forcé
à partir de là fallait le voir on nomme
ces trois là encore mieux parce que je
pense que les blancs sont complètement
lycée mais c'est pas mal aussi d'un
prend tout reprend et bien sûr dame b 2
échecs gagnent une pièce ou h3 d'emprunt
ou de nina est entré encore une fois de
gagner deux camps biblique ou d'affilée
c'est extra ordinaire moi j'ai deux
dents prend parce qu'il ya une menace il
y avait une masse attention regardez ici
la dent prend si on protège le pur à 4
on peut dans b5 ce genre de truc mais on
se fait matt et trey c'est que la ja van
damme mat
donc on n'a pas trop le choix faut jouer
roger 2 j'ai encore quelques couacs
suhavo mais après d'emprunt 4 on voit
bien que c'est déjà foutu dans mes
cavaliers bon encore jouer quelques
coups
ces rentes ont la forme échec voilà dame
f2 et abandonneront ici de souza au
barça citrine énorme surprise donc souza
vous qui était quand même position de
l'emporter un peu comme harry sebag face
à la russe pogonat et qui se fait un
remonter dans donc là dans la deuxième
partie et qu'il a se fait battre dans la
première rapide et elle va faire que nul
dans la seconde un regard dont un petit
peu les résultats de ces quarts de
finale et après on va regarder un petit
coup d'oeil au tableau donc suazo a
perdu la première dans ce magnifique
gambie benko là on prend une leçon
dedans me benko dans ce championnat du
monde par natalia pogo nina qui en sort
deux de suite peut-être les avaient
réservé d'ailleurs pour la fin de match
et
on a aussi donc ici voilà parties nulles
en seconde pour godina qui assure la nul
et donc sa qualification pour les demi
finales voilà ça c'est pas mal alors
ensuite koné hockey ce café koné ou
alors elle fait nul dans la première
phase à marianne aux i took et dans la
seconde
ici je trouve le match voilà non c'est
pas là ces voix là
koné roux nous ichu 0 1 voilà est le
père est le père donc je vous laisserai
regarder la partie moi parlons pas
commenté les tie-breaks tous le tabac et
loyers ça fait beaucoup trop de partis
s'est départi rapide en plus et donc
qu'on est roux perd la seconde est donc
se fait éliminer donc sous à éliminer
conejo éliminé c'était quand même les
deux joueuses les plus fortes de a
priori selon le classement elo et puis
aussi leur historique de carrière un qui
était quand même les plus fortes
joueuses du tableau mais non non non
c'est les plus jeunes qui l'emportent
natalia pogo nina qui se qualifie
maria musi tchouk la première des soeurs
musique zouk et dans le second tie break
ça c'était extrêmement tendue puisque
ana musique tout cas d'abord perdu la
première puis égaliser mais elle perles
les seconde partie rapide puisqu'il n'
ya quatre ans tout voilà ici
kra mig puis akrami la suédoise donc
remporte la première partira la
troisième partie rapide et enfin assure
la nul ce qui lui permet elle aussi
d'accéder aux demi finales alors qu'elle
ça va être quoi le tableau un petit coup
d'oeil
voilà
regardez les demi finales ça va être dit
ici donc
maria mozy tous qualifiés natalia pogo
dina pierre cram ming et arica voilà
donc des demi-finales qui vont être
extrêmement intéressante à jouer
extrêmement tendue aussi arica était
dans le tableau de koné roues donc on va
avoir
arica maria nous itruc et natalia togo
nina face à pia cramer ling très beau
match très tendu cela très intéressant
puisque pierre cramier la plus
expérimentée tout de toutes ces joueuses
l'aem plus âgés bien plus âgé plus une
carrière beaucoup plus longue donc c'est
gérer ces moments là mais natalia
proglio on l'a vu un très grand talent
pour l'essentiel qui m'impressionne le
plus dans ce championnat du monde depuis
qu'elle a battu mary sebag
on voit bien là ici qu'elle a réussi un
très beau match aussi donc on va suivre
ça après dans la suite de ce championnat
du monde 2015 féminin voilà merci de
m'avoir suivi sur des modèles tv pour
ces tie-break du championnat du monde
2015 et je vous donne rendez-vous donc
pour les demi finales au revoir